هذه المنطقه كنا فيها يوم امس في هذا
الموقع بالذات كانت فرق الانقاذ تبحث عن
عالقين تحت الانقاض مع الاسف لم
مع الاسف لم يتمكنوا من العثور على ناجين
انما وصلوا الى بعض الجثث وقاموا برفع
وقاموا بانتشال الجثث وبالتالي انتهت
عمليات البحث في هذا الموقع كما في مواقع
عديده هنا في نوردا وما تزال عمليات البحث
مستمره في بعض المواقع لكن
كما تشاهدين يعني حجم الدمار في هذه
المدينه كبير وكبير جدا هم يعني حتى الان
عمليه ازاله الانقاذ لم تبدا من معظم
المواقع كانوا كانت كل جهود منصبه على
عمليات
البحث والانقاذ لكن حتى الان عمليه رفع
الانقاض لم تبدا في هذه المنطقه في عديد
المواقع حجم الدمار في هذه المدينه كبير
جدا احياء بالكامل انهارت
وعشرات المباني
اصبحت غير صالحه للسكن حتى المباني
السليمه وعددها قليل السلطات ترفض
لاصحابها السماح بالعوده اليها خوفه من
الهزات الارتزاديه التي لم تتوقف في غازي
عنتاب الليله الماضيه كان هناك هزه
ارتداديه طبعا
يعني امام هذا الدمار امام حجم هذا الدمار
كل سكان المدينه او كل سكان البلده
حاليا هم في اماكن ايواء مؤقته بما انك
ذكرت اماكن وطبعا البشر هم من اهم يزيدان
في مثل هذه الكوارث وبعد ان يعني تم انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه من تحت الانقاض الان من
بقي على قيد الحياه بعد هذه الكارثه جهود
الايواء اين وصلت وهل يتم الاستجابه
لاحتياجات
لانه كان هناك الكثير من القصص لاناس طروا
لامضاء اكثر من اسبوع في سيارتهم بعد ان
فقدوا منزلهم دون الحصول على خيمه واحده
نعم بالضبط يعني رغم كل المساعدات التي
وصلت هناك البائع هناك بعض
العائلات لم تتمكن من الحصول على خيم
وطبعا الخيام ليست هي الحل يعني في
النهايه الخيام هي مكان مؤقت وعده ايام من
المفترض ان لا اكثر لان هذه القيم على
سبيل المثال هذه الخيمه يعني لا يمكن ان
تقي من بروده الطقس وايضا يمكن ان تكون
امام اختيار ما بين وخيمه فالخيمه على
الاقل يعني تمثل سقفا فوق رؤوسهم نعم نعم
طبعا طبعا هنا نتحدث عن ادنى مقومات
الحياه بلا شك طبعا نحن تابعتهم على شاشه
العربيه المقابلات التي اجريناها صباح امس
مع اشخاص كما ذكرت كانوا يبيتون لمده
اسبوع في السيار في السياره وبعضهم ايضا
كان
خرج يناشد يريد خيمه يعني كما تحدثنا رغم
ان غالبيه سكان نورداث الغالبيه العظمى
حصلوا على قيام لكن بعض العائلات لم تتمكن
من الحصول
لذلك يعني المساعدات المستمره نامل ان يتم
حل هذا الموضوع لكن كنت اتحدث عن الخيام
ايضا هي ليست الحل لذلك بلديه غازي عنتاب
تعمل الان على بناء
مخيم كبير او ما تسمى مدينه كبيره او مجمع
سكني مكون من كرفانات هذه الكرفانات عباره
عن غرفه
وملحقاتها سيتم نقل قسم كبير من سكان هذه
الخيام الى هذه الكرفانات كحل مؤقت لحين
نقلهم الى ولايات اخرى طبعا استمرار
العيش او البقاء في هذه المدينه على ما
اظن انه مستحيل لحين اعاده اعمارها
المدينه بحاجه اعاده بناء احياء جديده
بالكامل لاعاده تاهيل البنى التحتيه ومن
ثم اعاده بناء المرافق العامه